avez vous déjà eu l'impression de
traverser la vie en courant sans prendre
le temps de vous arrêter pour la vivre
il y a fort longtemps dans la taïga
cette forêt sombre du nord vivait un
loup solitaire
un jour le loup blessé à la patte
ce mythe en recherche d'un coin
tranquille et sécurisant où dormir jour
et nuit
dormir jusqu'à sa guérison les jours
passent et même si la fin le tiraille
il ne bougera pas à l'apparition de
cette biche toute proche
il n'en fera rien car il sait le lou
sait qu'il doit être complètement
rétabli pour ne pas risquer sa vie dans
une attaque aux chances de réussite
minimes le loup c'est que prendre son
temps et écouter ses besoins est une
question de survie
pendant
al'inverse du loup j'ai cru pendant
longtemps que pour exister il fallait
s'agiter faire produire construire
quitte à tourner en rond je croyais qu
en m'arrêtant jallet disparaître je
croyais que l'entrepreneur pour réussir
doit travailler dur et être constamment
en action je croyais que ma valeur était
indexée sur mes heures passées au bureau
le nombre de mes clients la taille de
mon équipe et le montant de mon chiffre
d'affaires mon agenda plein à craquer
emma perpétuelle course effrénée était
pour moi symbole de réussite alors qu'il
me donnait seulement l'illusion d'une
consistance
un peu comme cette cigarette fumée
devant le collège lorsque l'on est
adolescent pour se donner une contenance
à 30 ans je suis à bout de souffle tout
envie en mois a disparu
mais à quoi bon tout ça sommes nous
vraiment ici sur terre pour passer la
majeure partie de notre temps dans un
bureau pour gagner notre vie et
rembourser des crédits et si je
commençais à vivre c'est décidé pendant
trois mois je mets mon entreprise sur
pause
je m'organise dans les moindres détails
pour ne pas la mettre en péril
évidemment je suis terrifiée à l'idée de
détruire ce que j'ai mis tant de sueurs
et d'énergie à construire je pars loin
de tous en quête de vide de silence de
temps pour trouver un sens avec l'espoir
de me rencontrer ma destination sera
l'alaska territoire immense sauvage où
les villes sont reliées entre elles par
bateau chaque semaine un port une église
quelques maisons autour plus la ville
est petite moins il ya de choses à y
faire plus j'y reste longtemps
c'est ainsi que j'expérimente de me
laisser aller à des journées vides
d'obligations et de choses à faire
j'ai tout mon temps
chaque silence chaque son chaque pas
chaque goutte de pluie ou apparition de
baleine est une merveille et je
m'émerveille jeu redéploie mes sens
aller coûte de cette nature qui
m'entoure je suis ému de faire partie de
ce grand tout bien plus grand que moi
bien plus grand que nous je renoue avec
la contemplation
je m'autorise l'oise yves t et la poésie
l'expérience que je fais commence alors
à prendre sens accueillir la beauté le
mystère la magie l'émotion en moi de me
sentir en vie alors je ne vous cache pas
qu'après des mois ce rythme le retour à
paris fut brutal bureau contrat agenda
m'entraîne de nouveau dans leurs
cadences infernales
j'ai fait l'expérience du vide face au
trop plein à présent comment trouver
l'équilibré entre ces deux extrêmes
parce que ma vie se déroule maintenant
dans la multitude de petites choses qui
font au quotidien
jour après jour semaine après semaine
ma perception du temps est la clé de
voûte qui tient l'ensemble le temps
qu'on tient absolument tout il est cet
espace dans lequel se déploie le souffle
la vie c'est une ressource que je ne
peux ni stoker pour plus tard ni
récupérer une fois qu'elle a été
utilisée comme mon énergie et ma
présence
et pourtant je les dilapide à tout-va
courant d'une activité à une autre sans
même m'en rendre compte
on le sait bien le développement de
l'industrie a plébiscité l'horloge et
l'agenda qui découpe notre temps de
façon linéaire et le rendre quand
fiable le temps devenu chaîne de
production est monétisable vous moi nous
achetons le temps de l'autre où nous
vendons notre temps de vie ce qui
engendre chez moi la volonté de le
rentabiliser
vous savez bien faire plus en moins de
temps car quand je ne produit rien de
tangible économiquement
j'ai la sensation d'être inutile alors
je ne sais pas pour vous mais moi je me
suis acharné à en faire le plus possible
en 24 heures et souvent je culpabilisais
de ne pas en avoir fait assez
comment sortir de ce schéma de
fonctionnement en commençant par
accepter nos limites inhérentes à notre
condition d'être humain
j'accepte enfin qu'il m'est impossible
de tout faire d'être partout et de tout
vivre
je vous invite aujourd'hui à choisir en
conscience à quoi vous dédiez vos
précieuses ressources à allouer votre
temps votre énergie et votre présence à
ce qui vous importe vraiment quel projet
quelle activité
quelle relation qu'elle rêve un peu
moins connu que son théorème pythagore
disaient les deux mots les plus brefs et
les plus anciens oui et non sont ce qui
exige le plus de réflexion quand vous
dites oui à ceux ci à quoi renoncer vous
quand vous dites non à quelle
opportunité vous ouvrez vous
être constamment débordé m'offrait une
sorte de confort
cela m'évite est d'avoir un faire face
aux questions sans réponse enfoui en moi
que reste-t-il de moi sans l'étiquette
social de l'entrepreneur qui suis-je
lorsque je laisse tomber costumes et
masques lorsque je laisse au placard ses
vêtements de parisienne et ses bijoux de
créateurs qui me donne le sentiment
d'être unique
qui suis-je sans ma carte de visite et
mon téléphone portable à quoi je sers
qu'elle va offrir au monde bon là vous
vous dites sûrement que je me pose trop
de questions et ceux qui me connaissent
en savent quelque chose
et aujourd'hui devant vous j'assume de
formuler toutes ces questions finalement
c'est en les accueillant en acceptant de
traverser l'inconfort qu'elle générait
en moi pour les regarder en face que
j'ai commencé à entendre leurs réponses
mes aspirations profondes ont émergé
d'une lente et silencieuse décantation
éclairant d'un jour nouveau
mes choix de vie c'est à 15 ans que j'ai
lancé ma première activité
professionnelle et pendant toutes ces
années à prototyper et développer des
idées de business très variés j'ai
expérimenté les méthodes si chère à
l'entrepreneuriat business plan business
model intelligence collective design
thinking and co tout cela nourrit c'est
mon besoin d'autonomie de liberté de
nouveautés et mon ego bien sûr mais j'ai
découvert que ça ne garantit pas de
répondre aux aspirations profondes de
l'être humain derrière l'entrepreneur
que chercher à l'extérieur le sens de
notre vie plutôt que de le chercher en
nous et précaires que cherchèrent à
l'extérieur le sens de notre vie est
plus précaire que de le chercher en
je comprends que la vie professionnelle
et personnelle ne sont pas les deux
faces d'une même pièce
pierre après pierre jabala murat et que
j'avais érigé entre le pro et le perso
pour enfin réunir toutes les parties de
moi
je décide alors de ne plus aborder la
vie par le prisme du travail pour entrer
en relation au monde à travers ce qui me
fait me sentir vivante
je sors des cases des business models
pour créer intuitivement une activité
qui soit le prolongement de mon être
elle prend de multiples formes réintègre
tout ce qui fait partie de moi et que
j'avais délaissé en grandissant faute
d'y voir une utilité dans notre monde
productiviste
elle allie l'exploration à la création
avec l'intention de rendre visibles les
connexions entre tout ce qui fait notre
façon d'habiter et d'être au monde
elle me permet de contribuer à plus que
moi en étant moi elle est vivante
nourrissante et contributive il m'aura
fallu de burn out et l'expérience du
vide en alaska pour intégrer en moi la
sagesse du loup intégré comme autoriser
le repos la détente ne rien faire ne
fait pas de moi une personne moins bien
ou moins performante
c'est même plutôt le contraire j'ai
expérimenté dans mon corps est dans mon
âme que plus je suis à mon écoute plus
je m'autorise l'oise yves tu es sans
culpabilité lorsque j'en ressens le
besoin
plus je suis créative efficace et
impactante dans les temps dédié au
travail
ne dit on pas que l'intuition et
l'inspiration surgissent du silence je
sais aujourd'hui que mon intuition prend
les bonnes décisions dans tout ce que
j'entreprends
même si cela ébranle les croyances ne
répond pas à ce que l'on attend de moi à
ce qu'il est convenu de faire alors
concrètement ça veut dire quoi
que je décide de faire tomber de son
piédestal la valeur travail
j'arrête de croire que la perfection
existe le perfectionnisme poussé à
l'extrême devient le pire des tyrans
pour soi et pour les autres je m'éloigne
de mon fantasme de petite fille parfaite
et de sa peur de ne pas exister
autrement
à présent je sais que même lorsque je ne
fais rien j'existe je m'autorise à être
aimés tels que je suis imparfaite et
pour cela je commence par mémé pour qui
je suis plutôt que pour ce que je fais
c'est une métamorphose intime que de
m'ouvrir à une autre façon de faire en
commençant par être il m'a fallu
renverser les nombreuses croyances que
j'avais sur le travail sur la réussite
sur le temps sur la paresse sur la vie
pour être dans mon entièreté
il m'a fallu déconstruire le plein pour
explorer le vide et me sentir vivre de
l'intérieur se vider plus féconds qu'une
course effrénée à l'accumulation de
biens et de choses à faire
il m'a fallu apprendre à remplacer mon
besoin de contrôler par la confiance
jour après jour apprendre à lâcher prise
le compte de notre loup blessés que je
vous ai raconté tout à l'heure je les
écris pour transmettre d'être attentif à
nos ressentis et d'accueillir les
variations d'énergie qui font le cycle
du vivant tel le loup j'adapte mon
agenda à mon propre rythme je surf sur
les périodes où je suis dynamique motivé
est ouverte pour réaliser mes projets
être pleinement relations avec mes
clients et partager des moments en
famille ou entre amis ai je choisi
d'arrêter de me faire violence
lorsque je suis là ce que j'ai besoin de
repos et de rien
j'embrasse ces périodes de creux avec
confiance dans l'alternance des cycles
comme le printemps met fin à l'hiver un
lassabe le mans
aujourd'hui je peux vous dire que mon
quotidien est beaucoup plus doux plus
fluide plus joyeux j'ai gagné en mieux
être et je vais vous dire j'ai même
gagné en vie et parce que cela a changé
mon quotidien
j'ai à coeur de transmettre chacun des
éléments de cette alchimie autour de moi
au travers de mes livres d exploration
que je guide de mes conférences et
création s'écouter ralentir sentir se
relier à la nature et s'ouvrir à l'être
plutôt qu'aux faire ou à la voir se
rencontrer pour partir de soi pas comme
un but mais comme le chemin vers une vie
choisi un quotidien en conscience et
douceur pour enfin s'ouvrir à la magie
de la vie à l'âme qui agit être en
harmonie avec soi les autres et le
vivant et vous à quel endroit pourriez
vous mettre davantage de vide dans votre
vie êtes vous prêt à accueillir vos
aspirations profondes à vous offrir la
liberté d'être
alors pour ne plus jamais oublié de
vivre
je garde en mémoire c'est petit écriteau
accroché aux portes des commerces à
juneau capitale de l'alaska sur
lesquelles était écrit ces trois mots
fermé pour soleil
[Applaudissements]